[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Greetings, everyone.
So before I start
sharing my screen,
let me ask if there
are any questions
from the last lecture.
OK.
So, where are we
in terms of class?
We have a review session today.
The exam is next Thursday,
and it covers material
from lectures 8 through 15.
And I'm going to take
questions on those,
or scroll through them,
or review, or something.
So that's the main
thing that's happening.
So the overview of that
is we did the theory,
and then we started
in risk-sharing,
with two applications,
including production.
We went to financial modeling.
Then we went to contracts to get
at obstacles, like information
and moral hazard problems.
We did a theory lecture of
sorts, links to Bitcoin,
and ledgers, and then
another application lecture.
We went to international trade
in the context of all raising
equilibria, and we did two
trade lectures, including
the one we did last time.
So that's the overview.
Some words about the exam,
again, even though in principle
the thing is
comprehensive, that's
because it's building on
material that had previously
been covered.
But the focus will be on
the material from lectures 8
through 15.
And again, because it's
limited to 80 minutes,
there's no way I can ask a
question about everything
you might be anticipating.
But hopefully, the
questions themselves
are reasonable, and fair,
and not terribly surprising
if you've been following the
lectures, doing the p-sets,
and keeping up to date.
And you have all the review
session material, as well.
That's the best guide
to the lectures,
or there was review
questions we do
at the beginning of each class.
Which brings me
to the next thing.
So here's the study guide.
And let's start with what we did
last time, focusing on the US.
I talked about China shocks and
accounting identities, which
led up to this question using
the lens of the accounting
identities.
What is the preliminary
evidence for the impact
of China shocks on the variables
of the current account?
Somehow, I'm in the mood to take
volunteers, rather than call
on you.
Any volunteers for that?
Quiet group today.
Well, I will--
how about Charles?
AUDIENCE: Oh, let's see.
I think I haven't got around
to watching your last lecture
recording yet.
So I'm not exactly sure.
But oh, yeah.
Sorry.
Is it this one?
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Yeah it's in and out,
synchronous and asynchronous.
How about is someone
ready to volunteer?
China shock financial
accounts and what did we find?
AUDIENCE: I can try.
I'm also very unsure.
But is this about looking
at the current account,
and how the trade balance
would be negative.
And then that's kind of
giving us evidence about how--
the China shock was about how
since low-skilled workers,
we have less of that
commodity and more
of high-skilled workers.
So then we're like
low-skilled workers are
going to be losing in trade.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
That's also true.
So I was in part
looking for this thing
about the current
account deficit.
And so, yes, it's
interstate trade and states
that are hit the
worst by China shock,
meaning that their local
manufacturers had to compete
with these Chinese imports.
Those states export
less to other states,
and also to some
extent, import more.
Does anyone remember what
else is on the left-hand side
of the current account?
Current account consists of the
trade balance plus something.
AUDIENCE: Net income?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Net income,
yeah, so meaning gifts incoming
or remittances for
factor payments
earned in other states.
And does anyone remember?
Did it go up or down?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
Go ahead.
I was going to say that I
think transfers were positive.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, good.
OK.
So this linked up
to risk-sharing.
And I'm not sure if I
emphasized it last time.
But given that it's
quote, a "shock," a China
shock, or at least
an adverse trend,
the question is,
what arrangements
would cover these shocks?
Public transfers
in principle could
have done that through
fiscal taxes and transfers.
But what we found
in the data was
that it was the private
transfers that seemed
over a 10-year period to go up.
So it definitely relates to
all the risk-sharing stuff
we did in the last few
lectures and that we
are about to review today.
And what about the other
side of the current account,
financial stuff,
anyone remember?
Maybe these financial
accounts are tricky.
Well, we'll review it today.
But we didn't find
very much adjusting.
On the right-hand side, we
should see a given state,
losing--
losing its claims on foreigners
in this other states,
in the sense of
running a deficit.
So they should be running
down their savings accounts,
and so on.
But so far, we haven't
found that in the data.
But it's still good to know what
was the financial adjustment
on the right-hand side, because
the accounts have to balance.
Let's do one more.
What in practice in the
US is the difficulty
in reconciling income flows
with the change in the balance
sheet?
That is to say explain what
accounting identity ought
to hold, and what in
contrast we actually
have in integrated macro
accounts and household surveys.
AUDIENCE: I think I could take
a shot at what identity might--
I think I know what
the identity is.
I'm not sure exactly how
it might feel though.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Isn't like, the
identity should probably
be something like
the expenditures
by households which
should be matched up
by the incomes to whatever
firm is selling the goods
or something like that.
Those two sides of
the balance sheets
should match up if it's within
a country within the country.
Right?
So it's something
like that, is it?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Well,
it has to do more
with what is the relationship
between flows and the income
statement, and assets
in the balance sheet?
AUDIENCE: All right.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: Sure, but
basically I think it all
should be able to
match in a sense
that we should be able to
account for these dollars
on both sides, in both the
flows and in the assets.
But because of the way that
the data is structured,
there's no basically
central accounting place
where all of these are accounted
for on a regional level
in a way that just like
has all of the data.
And so basically
nothing matches up.
But we had that table
with errors in the--
I forget what it was.
Like 20 plus or percent
or something like that.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Yes, that's correct.
Great answer.
So the logic of it is you have
flows in the income statement.
You have revenues less
expenses equal profits,
or for households net income.
And what they don't eat
or pay out as dividends,
they should be saving.
So the changes in the balance
sheet, some balance sheet items
ought to go up if households
or firms are saving.
And in practice, since
as was just said,
the balance sheet
and income statements
are not collected
at the same time,
we see very big discrepancies
between the two.
So the rest of the class last
time, almost up to the very end
was about what this
discrepancy means
for attempts to
measure inequality,
or the impact of
COVID, and so on.
So I'll just say
what I was trying
to do in the class is not
to get you to memorize
financial account identities,
but rather to think creatively
about how to use financial
account data, and so on.
Which brought me to
the very end, where
I talked about trying
to fill in those gaps,
and gathering detailed level
information from households
in West Virginia, and so on.
But I won't ask about that.
Well, that may come up
again today, actually.
So let's go to the
review from lecture 8
on, so I will try to highlight.
We did risk sharing in
India, in the villages,
and also in medieval England in
terms of dividing up the land.
I talked at the
beginning of the lecture
about the high-risk environment
and the way households could
respond to it, either
by diversifying
or by helping each other
out with financial gifts
and transfers, and
then ways to test.
So in India, we decided
to test by looking
at incomes and consumptions, and
not looking at the mechanism.
And in contrast, with
medieval England,
we focus more on whether
or not the mechanism
of dividing up land could
achieve an optimal allocation.
So then we went
through characteristics
of village economies.
And the main thing
here was the risk.
In particular, in
village India, we
looked at the risk
of harvest yields
on various crops, of crops by
soil type, of income by type.
And we uniformly
saw a very high risk
on all these categories, as
well as some diversification
possibilities.
So for income, not everyone
has the same income sources,
and there's high risk of each.
But the covariances are
sometimes relatively low.
So the focus here
was on the fact
that households are not
completely diversified.
If all the households
did the same thing
if, they planted the same
crops in the same soil,
and have the same
income sources then
their initial outcomes would
be essentially the same.
And if that's true, then
there's not much left to share.
But we see the opposite.
We see they're not diversified
over all these various crops,
and soils, and activities.
So there's a lot of
idiosyncratic risk.
And that was what was clear
from this picture of what
we call the Rocky Mountains,
where the ups and downs are not
together, not going up together
across households in a given
year, and so on.
Whereas, they do achieve
a lot of smoothing.
So something is
happening in the villages
that whatever mechanism it is,
is allowing them to smooth.
Now one question that's come up
in Piazza are these profiles.
I mean so this is
a bit of a review,
but kind of interesting.
We see this income
profile from low to high.
Households with a lot
of land are consistently
getting higher income,
despite the fluctuations.
And there's a big
compression here.
So something is
transferring income
from the landed households
to the landless.
But a little bit of this
profile does remain.
So it's not equal treatment.
It's not as though
everyone is getting
the same amount of everything.
There is heterogeneity
in the treatment.
What that mechanism
is, is not so clear.
It's some kind of, at
least over these 10 years,
redistribution of income
from the wealthy to the poor.
But it doesn't work perfectly.
It doesn't completely
equalize things.
So this lecture was
featuring something
we had done in the
previous one, which
is to determine the pareto
optimal allocation of risk,
we maximize lambda weighted
sums of expected utilities,
subject to the
resource constraint.
And this way of
dealing with problems
generalizes considerably and
in the subsequent lectures.
So when we solved
this problem, we
looked at the first
order conditions.
We could see that weighted
marginal utilities should
be equalized to a common
Lagrange multiplier.
And you can do the
algebra, and actually
solve for the consumption
that's supposed to result,
and get these kinds of
closed form solutions
having to do with consumption
moving with the aggregate,
and not moving at all
with idiosyncratic shocks,
if the risk sharing is optimal.
So here is another
version of it,
individual consumption co-moves
with aggregate consumption
for all the households,
but should not
move with things like
individual incomes
once we control
for the aggregate.
So we tested this model to see
whether these coefficients were
0 or not, and largely they are.
I mean there is some
residual risk that
is being borne by
the households,
depending on the village
and the source of income.
But the benchmark
was doing quite well.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ROBERT TOWNSEND: I
would be delighted.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I mean here, we assume--
I see the sample.
There was about 40
households in each villagers.
But in this model, we
assume that the households
should be large amount.
If not, then the
idiosyncratic risk
might not be shared, right?
And for example, if there was
just two households and two
situations, then although they
face the idiosyncratic risks,
but there was like 0.25
probability both of them
were facing negative
shocks and/or both of them
face the positive shock.
So they cannot share the risks.
So in this model, we assume
the sample is large enough.
That is why we think that the
idiosyncratic shocks will not
affect people's consumption?
Yeah, each household
consumption.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: OK.
So it's a great question.
What can we test if we only
have a subset of the households,
and are we being misled?
Well, actually you
could think about it
as testing for subsets.
And the theory holds.
Of course, what is aggregate
consumption for two
households would be different
from what it would be
if you had data on all of them.
But the theory still works
for two, or three, or just
a handful.
If they are bearing
risk optimally,
then they should be bearing
risk optimally in any subset.
Let me put that a different way.
The aggregate consumption within
the group may be moving around.
Individual consumptions in the
group should move with that.
The group consumption
actually could
look like an
idiosyncratic shock if we
considered the whole village.
So yet more
restrictions are implied
when we and if we had data
from the larger sample.
But you can still
test the theory
with a small number
of households.
It's just that it's
not as powerful.
You could reject, however.
Does that help?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: OK.
It was a great question.
So then the next
thing we did was
to take the same theory to
different applications, back
to medieval villages, and the
landholding patterns which
are spread out all over
the different fields.
And the idea is, does
that make sense or not,
and would dividing up the
land in that way exactly
achieve an optimal allocation
of risk bearing or not.
So we took the
different types of land
to have a different
vector of yields.
We talked about the
endowment, so to speak,
the yields of land type
k across states epsilon.
And then we have
capital K types of land
and capital S types of shocks.
We can look at the
covariance and the risk, just
the way we did in India.
So again, we get this
picture, very, very
risky with some
covariances pretty low.
And then I took you through
a series of examples
to see how close we could get
to an optimal allocation of risk
bearing.
The first was household
1 is all of land type 1.
Household 2 has
all of land type 2.
But these returns
do not co-move,
hence this would not constitute
an optimal allocation
of risk bearing.
Household 1 would go 10, 6.
Household 2 would go 2, 4.
So although the
aggregate is going down,
I should say, from 12 to 10,
household 2's consumption
if they ate all their own
crops would be going up.
So that's a restriction.
Then we considered a
different way of doing it.
Give those household shares.
Household j say
having a share alpha j
of the two different crops.
So now, this thing goes in
the aggregate 12, 10, 7.
Obviously whatever
household 1's share
is, if it's like one third,
it's 1/3 of that aggregate.
Household 2's shares would
be 2/3 of that aggregate.
So now they're each
bearing a constant share
of the aggregate and
their consumptions
are moving with the aggregate.
So that might actually work.
That's this.
And then we looked at
special utility functions,
and started fussing about
intercepts, and risk aversion,
and so on.
But then we come
to the general idea
that we have as many land types
with independent return vectors
as we have states of the world.
And then we have a target
optimal consumption allocation.
So we're trying to achieve
this allocation that
came from maximizing a lambda
weighted sums of utilities
by dividing the different
land types into shares.
Except now we have
even more power,
because we do not require
that household j have
the same shares and all
of the land types k.
We have this alpha jk for
household j in the land type k.
And it's not perfect.
But in general, since
this vector of endowments
is non-singular, you can
solve for the consumptions.
And one hopes that the shares
will be positive in the end.
So if there are as
many types of land
as there are states
of the world,
they have a shot at achieving
the optimum by entirely
dividing up the
land, and not having
to give gifts or transfers to
one another after the fact.
So then we come to--
we put in particular
utility functions,
and we assumed that
we're going to solve
this problem, maximizing lambda
weighted sums of utilities,
by the shares alpha jk.
But we're going to
assume that there
are fewer land types than
there are states of the world,
namely only two types
of land, and a larger
number as states of the world.
So now, we know we in general
cannot achieve an optimum.
But we were trying to describe
this constrained optimal
arrangement.
I guess what I want to emphasize
is despite the restrictions,
we're still solving this
programming problem.
We're maximizing
lambda weighted sums
of utilities subject
to constraints,
namely the shares
have to add up.
So the method of
achieving characterizing
pareto optimal
allocations is the same.
And then we looked to see
with those particular utility
functions how far off we would
be from achieving the optimum.
And here you can actually see,
as the aggregate endowment
moves the adjustment.
In other words, even if they
did as much as they could
by dividing up the two land
types, it would not be perfect.
And there should be incoming
or outgoing transfers
to try to make up the difference
to get to the full risk sharing
optimum.
And that was the
end of this lecture.
Are there questions
about what we did
or what we were trying to
accomplish in lecture 8?
So then the second of the
two application lectures
included production
in lecture 9.
And the main difference
between what we did just now
and this lecture, is we actually
have physical production,
rather than treating
output as an endowment.
But we still solve this
programming problem.
So we're maximizing
lambda weighted sums
of expected utilities,
just as before,
subject to resource
constraints, just as before.
The choice variables now include
the transfers, just as before,
but we also are
choosing which projects
to fund and by how much
capital investment.
So the reason that transfers
are the same as before,
is because we have
transfers or consumption.
You can move consumption
around by moving transfers.
So it's arbitrary choice
whether to solve for c or tau.
The more interesting
part, because it's
new to this lecture,
are these capital
stocks, which has to
do with deciding what
to do with the current wealth,
namely eat it or invested
in projects for tomorrow.
Here is the starting
point, w, which
is the trees and the
fruit from the trees.
And this was the ending point,
what to do, either eat or save.
Oh then, back to the
accounting identities,
you either eat something or
save something, as in the flows.
So we got two first order
conditions out of this problem,
one very familiar, lambda
weighted marginal utilities
are equated to each other.
We also got a new
equation having
to do with the marginal
utility of consumption today,
and the marginal utility
of consumption next period.
And those typically will
balance each other off
for any project they're running.
There was an issue that this
thing could have been negative,
in which case that project
would not be implemented,
because they would actually
not want to put stuff in there.
They'd want to take stuff out.
But they hit zero.
So the rest of it was
to take expressions
for these first
order conditions,
and start manipulating them.
I'm not going to
review that today.
It's algebra.
It's straightforward.
We can even make
some assumptions
about linear technologies,
subject to risk,
and quadratic utility functions.
And when we did that, we
got two expressions directly
from the theory that we
could take to the data.
One, we can measure
from the data
how household j returns
are moving with the village
aggregate return,
this beta being
a measure of the covariation
of household j's return
with the village average.
Then having used the panel
data to get these beta j's, we
look in the cross section to
see how the betas are related
to each other, and in particular
to the overall average
or expected return.
So the main empirical
finding here
was that returns
have to be higher
when the betas are
higher, because
those particular activities
from household j co-move
move a lot with the aggregate.
So in effect, it's very risky,
not so many diversification
possibilities come from
including household
j in the village portfolio.
And so if they're
going to be running
those projects of
household j, there
has to be a compensating
differential,
and that's the higher
expected return.
So then we started adopting this
language of risk premia, which
is the difference between
the expected return
and the risk-free rate.
The risk premia has to
compensate for the risk.
So then we went
to the Thai data,
where we have
everything we need.
We have the income
and the balance sheet.
Oh yeah, so here
are these accounts.
This, I think,
was the first time
the accounts started
to come up explicitly.
We used the Thai monthly
data over 13 years,
and I featured net
income to be profits,
to be revenue minus costs.
And then we looked
at the assets to be
assets of various
kinds, typically
physical tangible assets.
So here you have the income
statement and the balance
sheet.
I just didn't call
it that at the time,
but that's what we're using.
So then we tested
the model, and found
that the betas, the
expected returns,
are indeed higher when
the betas are higher,
just like the model predicted.
And here, we are back to
idiosyncratic and aggregate
risk, which was a
theme I mentioned
in the previous lecture.
We can decompose the aggregate
variation of household j,
and explain the
unexplained part.
The explained part has to
do with the covariation
with the village average.
And the unexplained part is just
there were some idiosyncratic
risk.
And we decompose
the risk premium
as well into the
part that's coming
from the village as a whole,
through the beta j, as well as
the sigma square sigma
j on that epsilon.
And then got another
decomposition.
So it turned out that,
as a quick review,
idiosyncratic risk was
the largest contributor
to total risk, and
aggregate village level
risk was a small part.
So there were a lot of
idiosyncratic shocks
in these villages,
just like we imagined
that there were in
medieval England,
and also that we documented
there were in village India.
But when you looked
at the risk premia,
it went the other way,
namely most of the risk
has to do with the
aggregate risk.
So that's consistent
with them finding a way
to diversify their
idiosyncratic shocks.
And there was evidence
that I presented
that they're doing that
by gifts, and borrowing,
and lending.
And that's the mechanism.
We started out talking
about how we weren't
going to test for mechanisms.
Then we looked at
ex-anti-division of land.
Now we're looking
at ex-post gifts
and borrowing as a way of
getting from their, quote,
"production endowments" to
their ultimate consumptions.
And most of the shocks are
covered, not all of them.
So they're not
completely following
the full risk-sharing
program, but they definitely
diversified mostly 90% of it.
So then we got to
particular health shocks,
and specific Illnesses,
and I showed you
that again those illness shocks,
not production shocks, per se,
also covered by gifts largely,
although not entirely.
And when they were
not covered, they
spill over into
the labor network
with less hiring
of employed labor,
and also less purchasing
of intermediate goods
from other households.
So this was documenting that.
So this is about
kinship groups and risk
sharing in village
villages in Thailand.
It also was about an
illness as a shock.
It was not about COVID,
although it was about illness.
The illness was idiosyncratic
and not aggregate.
The closest we could get in
the Thai data to an aggregate
was watching those shrimp
ponds suffer catastrophe
in one of the four provinces.
And because it becomes an
aggregate shock rather than
idiosyncratic shock, it's the
gifts didn't come in as much,
and it's very
harder to diversify.
So that's a theme I
keep mentioning now
for the last 10 or 15 minutes.
Idiosyncratic stuff, in
principle, you can diversify.
Aggregate stuff you cannot.
But the other thing I want
to draw your attention to
is this network stuff.
So the issue is not just
in Thailand or India,
for that matter, but do these
networks exist in the US.
And what's going on with COVID?
So that inter-state
risk-sharing stuff
suggests that networks
are not necessarily local.
They could be global.
But your relatives or
other family members
are engaged in risk
sharing when you
experience a shock back home.
And then this project in
West Virginia, well Michael,
I hope you don't
mind mentioning it.
But Michael, thinking
about networks,
wondered about
networks in the US
and the advantage of
collecting our own data,
indeed would be to better
measure the networks
among relatives,
or friends, and so
on, in towns in rural
areas in West Virginia.
So everything that we've been
doing featuring Thailand,
because we have all
that data, could
be done in other
contexts like the US,
if we can add that data.
And we've definitely
decided to try
to measure these
networks as a suggestion
that Michael had from last time.
All right.
So any questions
on this lecture 9?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
In the slides 19 data, when
we're decomposing the risk,
yeah, here.
I remember before we
have R [INAUDIBLE]
that was represented
the risk-free return.
But why here, we just have
beta and the idiosyncratic?
That is because we
both subtract the alpha
from left-hand side and
the right-hand side,
or because the
results we get before
that alpha is not significant,
so we don't care about it?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah,
another great question.
So there are two ways to do it.
We should have been thinking
about the rate of return
minus the risk-free rate.
But in fact, in the Thai
data, we took the position
that the risk-free rate was 0.
So that's why we
kind of dropped it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: It's
like having rice.
You can put rice in storage.
And you're going to get back
more or less what you put in,
et cetera.
So that was the
rationale for it.
Other questions?
OK.
So that was all the
stuff on risk sharing.
Then in lecture 10, we
started to introduce
these ledgers, and
financial accounts,
and other measurement issues.
Actually, there's a lot
going on in this lecture,
as I'll review with you.
We did the wealth planner
stuff, looking at the balance
sheet and the income statement.
Then I went to the
other statement,
the statement of cash flow.
And we thought about
Bitcoin as an example,
having the balance sheet, and
the cash flow in one place.
And with Bitcoin, that motivated
a review of distributed
ledgers, and how it works with
currency, physical currency,
as opposed to the ledgers.
And then we touched
on Sweden and Kenya.
So this lecture
introduced Bitcoin.
It also introduced distributed
ledgers as financial accounts,
and also value transfer.
So we talked about this
statement of income.
By now, you may or not remember,
it doesn't really matter.
This household A appears
twice subsequently.
This was the first
time we introduced it
as an example of the
income statement,
and also household
A's balance sheet.
And then we started to talk
about the wealth planner.
So we implemented
this in Thailand,
maximize discount expected
utility over the lifetime,
even allowing for
bequests to their kids,
subject to the stocks
and flows constraint,
investing in risky
and safe assets,
and allowing for the risk
sharing which you don't usually
see in wealth planners.
But we know we needed
it for Thailand,
because you've already seen
how much risk sharing there is.
So we want to smooth
out the income
profile consistent with the
ins and outs of those gifts.
And the residual is the
household's exposure
to their own income shocks.
So we explained to
those Thai households
how the planner works.
And again, to
motivate this, think
about going to the doorstep
of a household living
in West Virginia, having
collected some of their data.
Or better yet, what
data do we want
to collect in West Virginia
consistent with running
this wealth planner, so
we can give them advice?
The setting would be different,
but the idea is the same.
So with the wealth
planner, we find out
how much they're planning
to give to their kids,
if anything.
We calibrated their
income processes
with trends and fluctuations.
We looked at their
committed consumption goals,
and we're very careful
about their initial wealth.
Again, you come into the
period with a certain amount
of wealth, and you could consume
it, or you could save it.
You can save it and
risky or safe assets.
In principle, you
could also borrow,
and then that is going to
determine wealth for next time.
So I probably didn't
emphasize it as much.
But this is where
the stocks and flows
are coming together again
early on, through this budget
constraint.
Initial wealth and
consumption is subtracted off,
and the remainder goes into
risky and safe assets, which
will determine wealth next time.
And then we looked
at actual flows
in the data, the
second household,
the recommendation of the
planner in terms of life cycle
which is saving up
enough when you're
relatively young to be able
to survive through older ages.
Some of these households
get in trouble.
So we try to help this guy,
giving advice and actually
talking about the
realism of the goals.
And I made the point that this
planner exists for the US.
Although I don't know that
it's particularly well designed
for households in
West Virginia, it
does take into account
details of the US tax code,
and Social Security, and so
on, but acting as if there's
no networks, no risk sharing.
Who knows?
We'll eventually find out.
Then I made this transition
to Bitcoin as an account.
So Bitcoin accounts have
the ownership of the coin,
and also a way to
buy something else
and transfer the coin
to a third party,
by sending the proposed
transection to be validated.
So the Bitcoin ledgers
are a combination
of the balance sheet and
the statement of cash flow.
And with the introduction
of the idea of cash flow,
I went back to the
Thai financial accounts
to look at that
for the first time.
We'd already looked at the
income and balance sheet
statement.
Now we're looking at
the cash flow statement.
Cash flow from production,
consumption, financing,
and so on.
So then the issue is,
what do the ledgers do?
Well, in Thailand, they're
largely using paper currency.
So they do not keep accounts.
And there are no common ledgers.
Bitcoin is all on an account,
and there are common ledgers.
That's why it's called a
distributed common ledger.
So we actually went
to create ledgers
that would be common
in the Thai data,
and discovered a lot
of data discrepancies
because we hadn't
collected the data that way
in the first place.
This is also a
reminder, if we're
collecting data in
West Virginia and we're
getting the identity of
the transacting partner
when we interview that
partner, those transactions
should also show up.
So ideally one would
do that in real time
almost, when memory
is fresh, or for that
matter their understanding
of a transection
with a commercial bank
which is opposed to what
commercial bank is doing.
At least you think
that, of course,
the commercial banks are honest.
Just remember Wells Fargo
that actually created accounts
for households they
didn't know about,
and then charged
them money for it.
So we then talked about
the advantage of Bitcoin
like distributed ledgers,
namely data reconciliation.
But in practice, of course,
they're using paper currency.
So with that
opportunity, we looked
at another problem
of management,
which is managing the currency,
managing the cash flow, which
we modeled and fit to the
data, as having trends
and stochastic fluctuations.
We have the evolution
of cash flow,
adjusted taking into account
the ups and downs with shocks
of revenues and
expenses, and adjusted
by withdrawals and deposits.
The two costs were
going to the bank
to make the physical
adjustment, and the opportunity
cost, foregone
interest, of holding
the currency in the house.
Which led to another
optimization problem.
Now minimizing the
expected costs,
let me just say that our
vision for West Virginia
is to combine the high frequency
cash flow with the longer term
life cycle.
Because in practice they
are intimately related.
So we'll have a synthesis
of those frameworks in mind.
And in Thailand, they didn't
manage the currency very well.
In the rural areas, they're
holding far too much of it.
And in the urban areas,
they actually did better.
Of course, one
advantage of getting
them to switch
from paper currency
into electronic entries
that is then in principle,
it's easier to manage portfolios
or to send reminders about cash
management on apps on phones,
if all the transactions
are electronic.
And I give you some
examples of Yodlee
and other apps that do this,
that collect electronic data.
So anyway, that led
finally to, well,
do you have to use
paper currency?
The answer being no.
Sweden doesn't much
anymore, although they're
worried about it in
the sense of worried
that the private sector takes
over all of the payments,
and the Riksbank isn't needed
anymore, the central bank.
And the stuff in
between, which was Kenya,
so Kenya eMoney, digital money,
is created by the cell phone
company, allowing people
to cash in and cash
out, and electronically
transfer the credits on the cell
account, which turned out
to help with guess what?
Risk sharing.
So you see a tie-in here back
to those risk-sharing lectures.
In this case, it's in
the context of Kenya,
and the fact that your
kin back in the village
have had a terrible
harvest can be
mitigated by having the
migrant worker in Nairobi
send more money.
And evidently, that
is exactly what
happens, as opposed to having
to give the Kenyan shillings,
paper currency, to a friend.
Put it in an envelope,
hope for the best,
or in a very costly way go back
home and hand over the cash.
So risk sharing on the
ledgers actually helped.
But these are private accounts.
So they don't have
what we typically
refer to as distributed
ledgers, where
there's third-party validation.
All of these transactions,
cell phone companies accounts,
are trusted to be accurate.
Households can check
them, when they
happen to see if
they get credited
the way they're supposed to.
But other than that, Safaricom
could steal the money
if they wanted to.
They don't, evidently.
They put it in the
bank, but still,
and the banks are
subject to runs.
So there's a lot
of risk remaining,
even though this digital
currency is an innovation
in the context of Kenya.
It certainly would not be
in the context of Sweden.
They have their own
interbank method.
So are there questions
about this lecture 10?
Again, it's kind of a mouthful.
This lecture does both
the financial accounts,
income statement, balance
sheet, and cash flow,
and is also looking at two
problems namely cash management
and lifecycle management,
and finally merging
into a discussion of what
distributed ledgers, Bitcoin
and distributed
ledgers, do or don't do,
and potential substitutes.
How good or how bad is currency
and Safaricom digital credits,
relative to validated systems?
Although we haven't really
talked about validation.
That happens I think
in the next lecture.
So that was lecture 10.
Lecture 11 was about contracts
and mechanism design.
And I'll just give an overview.
There were two parts
to this lecture.
The first part is
figuring out what
to do when there's
private information.
And the main conclusion
was there is a way
to write down additional
constraints, called truth
telling or incentive
constraints,
that capture the problem
of private information.
And we will be able
to append those
on top of the usual
programming problems
that maximize the lambda
weighted sums of utilities.
So we've got a
tool, and the tool
is getting better and
better, because we
can do more and more with it.
So that was one of the
main points of this.
And the other was to
think about mechanism
design, private contracts,
having to do with messages,
and then back to
the ledgers which
have to do with the
cryptography part of ledgers,
and keeping messages secret,
and whether or not they
have to be validated.
So the motivation
for the first part
was the fact that
some of these villages
lie far away from the
central monastery.
Some are very near.
Some households work
as serfs, slaves.
Others far away pay rent.
So we wanted to explain
this kind of variation
in the organizations
that we see.
So we introduced a simple
two-agent model, where only one
of the two, agent 1, had some
privately observed endowment.
Agent 2 was the villa
or the monastery.
And we wanted to know what
would be an optimal resource
allocation mechanism,
granted that agent 1 has
private information.
So we did some derivation,
had agent 1 sending messages,
looked at what would be
a maximizing message,
derived a series
of inequalities,
and then changed the
problems to sending messages
about the underlying
endowment, and ended up
with something we call the
truth telling constraint, which
captures all of the
problems associated
with private information
in this context.
So then we're able to solve for
optimal resource allocations
just by adding on these kinds
of incentive constraints,
in addition to maximizing
the lambda weighted sums
of utilities.
We did this in levels.
Then we went to lotteries
to make it more general.
We had a good discussion
at the beginning of one
of the classes of the advantages
of these lotteries, which
we had talked about in the first
one third of the class as well.
Oh, and at some point,
there was a starred article
on the reading list,
which was how to actually
code these things up.
It's more related
to the next lecture.
But anyway, trying not
to be abstract about it.
So then we went from one
period to two periods.
We solved the
two-period problem,
and had incentive
constraints, truth telling
constraints for both periods.
In this case, what
I was emphasizing
both the dynamic program
and how to work back
from the second period to the
first period sequentially,
but also the fact that
moving forward from the first
to the second, the message
is about underlying
unobserved states would
be key to implementing
the optimal information
constrained solution.
And by emphasizing
messages, I was already
anticipating contracts,
smart contracts,
written on ledgers where
messages replace transactions.
And the optimal solution
to that two-period problem
was neither full insurance
which wouldn't be feasible,
nor limited borrowing and
lending which was not optimal.
And again, in class, we
had a very good discussion
about this hybrid borrowing
and lending scheme.
We did costly
state verification.
I won't dwell on that, except
that over a range of shocks,
you don't need to be
verifying anything at all.
But it's still effective,
because there's the threat
of an audit for low claims.
And we went back and argued
that costly state verification
can help explain what we
saw in the initial part
of the lecture.
So here is where the transition
happened to distributed ledgers
again.
And there was a lot
of material here.
I kind of argued that encryption
was one third key element
of distributed ledgers.
We've seen it historically.
We see it in contemporary
applications.
It really breaks
down into encryption,
of incoming and
outgoing messages,
of hashing of data and others
so that it's uninterpretable
unless one wants to prove that
it was the original, which
is possible to do in crypto
graphic puzzles, which
are hard, but not
impossible to solve.
Bitcoin is using
various of those things,
including a way of organizing
the data through mining
as the validation.
And I emphasized that
mining was not the only way
to validate transactions on
ledgers, if you don't trust
Safaricom or some third party.
And I also emphasized
the encryption part,
which Bitcoin doesn't use,
homomorphic and that's
not quite fair.
The encryption part
for the messages
is related to
homomorphic encryption.
But Bitcoin doesn't use
multiparty computation.
So then we came back to the
essence of the lecture, which
was, what is the difference
between validation
on distributed ledgers and
incentives and mechanism
design, and the different
philosophies of economics
versus computer science?
Computer science assumes
that most nodes are
honest and reliable, and designs
algorithms on the assumption
that the honest nodes will
follow the algorithms,
and just have to have
enough total nodes
relative to the faulty
nodes in the population
for those protocols to work.
But if you take the mechanism
design point of view,
the protocols may not
be incentive compatible.
Economists assume everyone's
very selfish and maximizing.
So even the miners
in Bitcoin have
to have incentives to follow
the prescribed protocol.
And that point is
true more generally.
So that kind of led to the idea
that why not separate the two
things, write down the
contract or mechanism design
problem in code as
in a smart contract,
let the parties agree
to it and make sure
that it functions the way
they think that it does,
and then send messages
to implement it?
Those messages would be
encrypted through HE and MPC.
And that's a contribution.
The mechanism design literature
assumes we have a planner.
I hate that language.
And the planner is trusted
to implement the mechanism.
What encryption does
nowadays is to get rid
of trusted third
parties and planners.
Agents can keep
secrets from each other
and implement the
optimal contract.
The ledgers still play a role.
I mean as in
borrowing and lending,
you can sequester the collateral
and have it automatically
transferred to the lender if
the borrower were to default.
So we're not claiming that we
only need the cryptography.
We also need the ledgers.
On the other hand,
you don't need
to have all the line items of
the code in the ledger being
done, as with Ethereum,
on a distributed ledger,
because that's
really, really costly.
So again, there was a
lot in this lecture.
Questions about lecture 11?
Lecture 12 was the application
of contract theory.
And we took it to
the Thai villages,
and looked at occupation choice.
There's a couple of
things going on here.
One, we now know
how to incorporate
private information, and
incentives, and collateral
by just appending extra
constraints onto the problem.
So let me start
skipping a little bit.
Will the entrepreneur
take appropriate action?
Not necessarily.
If it's not seen, then
you have to induce it.
Will the entrepreneur
pay back the loan?
If not, you have to
have collateral, which
is another kind of constraint.
So here we have the household's
utility in consumption,
and a disutility of
effort, and potentially
risk neutral,
potentially risk averse.
And households vary by
talent, wealth, and schooling.
And we have they're running
a firm with stochastic output
as a function of
effort and capital.
And they can borrow.
This is the slide I was
kind of racing to get to.
So here is the
problem, which we posed
as maximizing the
utility of the borrower
or entrepreneur, subject to
the bank making zero profits.
So it's worth emphasizing
that in the previous lecture,
as we've been maximizing lambda
weighted sums of utilities
subject to resource
constraints, and incentive
constraints, and so on.
Well, here we made a
shift from maximizing
the utility of one party,
subject to a fixed utility
of the other.
Or here, the utility
of the entrepreneur
subject to a fixed and zero
profit level of the bank.
One could have solved
this problem the other way
around, to maximize the
profits of the bank subject
to a fixed reservation utility
on the part of the borrower.
You should get the same answers.
Of course, there are
many, many solutions--
if you allow profits
to be positive,
if you allow some of the surplus
to go to the bank, et cetera.
In fact, the borrower could
be pushed down to the point
that they're almost
indifferent to participating
if the banks are getting
the bulk of the surplus.
But what I want to emphasize is
it's all the same in the end.
Maximizing lambda
weighted sum of utilities
is the same as maximizing
the utility of one type,
subject to fixed utility of the
other, and then varying those.
So the rest of it was just
implementing the solution,
limited liability, moral
hazard, with separate equations.
And then we got to
this diagram where
I said, if there were no
constraints at all, that
would be like the full
information, full commitment
solution, hit the bull's eye, it
could be entirely moral hazard
and not limited liability.
It could be entirely limited
liability and not moral hazard.
Although in this case, if
you had both constraints,
you have two equations and
two unknowns, the capital
and the effort level.
So when those two
constraints are satisfied,
if they're both in
the program, you
get a solution that has
nothing to do with utility
maximization, because there's
only one point in the input
space where both
constraints are satisfied.
But in general, if you
have only one or the other,
you have both max utility and
then subject to constraints.
The rest of this lecture
was about implementation,
namely solving linear
programming problems
and trying to pick
parameters in such a way that
maximize the probability
that the model is true,
given what we see in the data.
Maximize the probability that
the data we see in reality
could have come from
the model by choosing
the parameters of the model.
That was the application.
And then we had the findings
that the constraints
varied by region.
Are the questions
about this lecture?
So lecture 13 is also loaded.
Although it's more recent.
I'm somewhat comforted, just
like the first review session,
by the time we get to
13 and then 14, 15,
you've already seen 15 tonight.
Today, we just reviewed it.
So we're actually getting
close to the end here.
This lecture did two
important things.
One, the theory
which was to define
the notion of
Walrasian equilibrium
within and without transfers.
And the second was to apply it.
So we get general
equilibrium solution
in a small open economy
with production.
All of this slide
had to do with,
remember what an economy means.
This is partly review of the
first one third of the class--
numbers of households,
numbers of firms,
what consumers do, what firms
do, aggregate resources.
We went over private ownership.
And again, we had a
very good discussion
at the beginning of
the following class
to review this slide in terms
of individual endowments
and ownership shares.
And the key definition
of Walrasian
equilibrium with
three items in it--
maximizing profits
for firms, maximizing
utility for households, and the
feasibility of the allocations
that result from those
two optimization problems.
The key being that prices
are the things that
allow the reconciliation.
You can do partial equilibrium.
We did.
You can solve for profit
maximization taking prices
as given.
You can solve for
utility maximization,
taking prices as given.
Here in general
equilibrium, we are only
allowing certain prices
where those decentralized
optimization problems are
consistent with each other
in the sense that supply
is equal to demand.
Oh, and then this
Edgeworth box, which
is like economists' favorite
environment, a sad statement,
putting the two types of
households on the axis
and talking about what a
competitive equilibrium would
look like.
And the price equilibrium
with transfers and the welfare
theorems, which so far
I have only stated,
although the last one
third of the class
next week will be focusing
in part on these welfare
theorems starting next week.
So then we did production
in the small open economy.
And we again went through this
algorithm pretty carefully.
So I don't think I want
to say too much about it,
too, too much.
But we simplify the
problem down into firms
hiring inputs and trying to
find the factor prices that
clear the input markets, taking
out external prices of goods
as given.
So we had the firms
maximization problem.
We wrote down that the
sum of the input demands
equal the endowments,
and reminded ourselves
of Shepard's lemma.
So we had a different
statement of the input demands,
which we could then solve,
especially in the 2 by 2 model.
Input demands are entirely a
function of input price ratios.
And with constant returns
to scale, it's even easier.
We can talk about
cost minimization
to achieve a unit
of output, and then
to scale up and down when we
get to determining output.
We talked about the
intensity of goods,
the factor intensity
of the different goods
with a definition.
Here was the cost curves
and their properties.
Concave, we solve for
the equilibrium factor
prices, where both firms
face common prices.
Hence, there's only
one point where
that's true on this diagram.
And then we went from
that to production.
From production, we were
able to solve for the input
quantities and the outputs.
And then we got the
external goods prices
by considering the
free trade equilibrium
with two countries determining a
price ratio moving from Autarky
to international trade.
So there were three theorems.
We had this
Heckscher-Ohlin theorem,
which someone mentioned
at the beginning of class
today, that the
returns to factors
depend on whether the
country is abundant in one
factor versus another one.
The Stopler-Samuelson,
having to do
with how factor
prices are moving when
we vary the price of outputs.
And that's all.
OK.
Are there questions
about this lecture?
AUDIENCE: Here the
HO theorem that it
says that in the
Autarky, the price
of the capital intensive goods
in the capital abundant country
will be buy down, so here buy
down means the relative price
wars in this
capital-abundant country
was lower than another
country, right?
Not the absolute prices?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: The good
that is being produced,
which is capital
intensive, if produced
in the capital abundant country,
should be relatively cheap,
because the other country
is abundant in labor
and scarce in capital.
So--
AUDIENCE: Yeah my
question is that these
are cheap means that the
relative price was cheaper.
I mean in this
capital-abundant country,
the relative price of these
capital intensive goods
was lower than the same
relative price of the capital
intensive goods in
another country,
like labor-abundant
country, right?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
When you look at this--
another great
question, thank you.
So when you look
at this diagram,
it's really only
the relative price
of the goods that matters.
It's like p1 over p2.
So there's a lot of things
that are relative here
that look like they're
in Heckscher-Ohlin stated
as absolute prices.
But it's really only
the relative price.
AUDIENCE: I get it.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: OK.
All right, so that
was lecture 13.
And the other two
lectures, 14, we
took that trade
model to Thailand
and did some more with
the financial accounts
to get not just individual
income and balance sheet
statements, but to aggregate
up those statements to get
to village asset accounts.
Village level savings accounts,
flows across the villages,
and so on.
But my time is up.
So I can't review it.
Of course, the other
thing we're doing
is taking that 2 by 2 model to
actual data with the exception
that the model here
actually did not
have constant returns to scale.
It had capital mobility,
whereas the 2 by 2 did not.
Factor prices
would be equalized,
even without factor flows.
The thing that's
mucking up the Thai data
is that there's a
borrowing constraint.
So we have both real
and financial flows,
subject to borrowing
constraints.
And lecture 15 was
what I reviewed
at the beginning of class.
Any questions about 14?
OK, well I hope you find
these reviews useful.
I must say, you should
all feel really good,
because you're doing
well in the class,
and we are covering
a lot of material.
The constant themes here
are theory, data, both,
lots of tools, lots of concepts.
By now, you're functioning
like actual real economists,
and the conversations
on Piazza reflect that.
So I'm really happy with
how the class is going.
And I hope you found
this review to be useful,
and to be a reminder of
how much you have learned.
All right.
Thank you very much.